so there's a very revealing moment on
CNN uh over the weekend related to uh
what we talked about in the opening uh I
want you to watch as one of CNN's law
enforcement analysts explains to CNN
hosts why illegal immigrants are more
likely to commit crime in New York than
in
Florida and is a very simple and rather
obvious reason that is stunning to the
CNN anchors that hear this uh so watch
this
moment
you don't you don't touch our police
officers you don't touch anybody thank
you everybody I mean we're hearing a
change when it comes to immigration in
general from President Biden on down do
you hear her talk about that it is also
directly related to the fact that these
were police officers does that have any
impact does that change anything well
it's so complicated because you know
you're a New Yorker you move through the
city every day as I do we see these
people we touch these people they're out
looking for work they're delivering our
food they're at the gas stations and the
car wash um I mean these are people who
came in waves you know 170,000 probably
to New York City um but within that
group this hardworking you know throngs
of people in search of Hope and a better
life there is this 1center you know
criminal element that looks at a
different opportunity here these
individuals I went over their rap sheets
yesterday multiple charges Grand larsy
robbery attempted robbery grand larsy
grand Arsy uh this particular crew
operated on mopeds and scooters they
were doing organized retail theft they
were doing snatches on the street
iPhones iPads clothing so on and so
forth um one of them that they are still
seeking has 10 charges on one day
because he's part of a pattern that's
been going on and I'm looking at the
dates that their arrest started which is
probably close to when they got here
they've only been here a couple of
months so what the detectives are
telling me is they have Crews here that
operate in New York do all their
stealing then go to Florida to spend the
money and then come back and I'm like
why don't they just stay in steel in
Florida and they said cuz there you go
to jail
oh fa
point oh Fair Point wow speechless so so
criminals are less likely to commit
crimes in places where they'll where
they will actually be
punished is that what you're telling
us I'm astounded
I I can't believe
it and and they were they were both
astounded uh they were astonished by
this
Revelation they didn't know what to say
they had to stop and process it for a
second criminals travel from Florida to
New York specifically to commit crimes
because they'll go to jail in Florida
and they don't want to go to jail like
just like anybody else in fact you know
maybe again if you're if you work for
CNN it surprises you to learn this but
even criminal don't want to go to jail
they they very much prefer not to most
of them okay and um and you have to
commit crimes anyway so so they they
prefer to commit them in a place where
jail is less likely February is the
month of love and everybody loves bacon
which means you're going to love getting
free bacon from good ranchers when you
subscribe to any of their 100% American
Meat boxes they'll add one and a half
pounds of Applewood smoked bacon to your
order for free for an entire year good
ranchers sources all of their meat from
local farms and uh and that means that
you can trust every single bite but it's
not just about taste it's about the
experience and memories associated with
it whether it's the mouthwatering smell
through the kitchen on a Sunday evening
or the joy of sharing a plate of bacon
wrapped appetizers with friends good
ranchers has a way of creating moments
that linger in people's hearts and taste
buds so fall in love with beef chicken
seafood and especially bacon All Over
Again by subscribing to goodranchers.com
use my code Walsh to claim $240 in free
bacon this offer is not available on
their site is an exclusive offer only to
my listeners that's goodranchers.com use
code Walsh for the best bacon in the USA
goodranchers.com American Meat delivered
so there's a lot going on here obviously
a lot we can say about of it most of it
related to the issue of illegal
immigration which which we've we've been
talking about but what the guy on CNN is
describing here is the simple concept I
mean putting the illegal immigration
aspect of it to the side what he's
describing as the simple concept of
deterrence Florida has deterrence and
New York doesn't Florida puts you in
prison for crimes which deters criminals
from committing them in Florida and and
they go to New York where there's
basically no deterrence where as we've
seen you could be a
non-citizen who commits a vicious
assault and you walk out of jail like
flipping off the cameras and you just
Walt out and then go wherever you want
get on a bus and go to California or
wherever they went um and that's because
so why does it work this way because
punishing crime is a deterrence against
Crime if you punish crime you get less
of it and in this case if there's a
place that punishes crime and a place
that doesn't punish it the place that
doesn't will get even more crime because
they're going to get the criminals who
live in the places where they do punish
it so they're going to get kind of like
crime tourism thing which is what New
York is experiencing and all this seems
very obvious but it was not obvious to
the CNN anchors um it's not obvious to
anybody on the left these days and
that's because in recent years the left
has bought into this absurd myth that
deterrence itself is a
myth they have decided that you cannot
deter crime by punishing it this is what
they actually believe this is what is
taught in
schools and it's a movement on the left
that goes deeper than you probably
realize um in fact I'll I'll elaborate
on it a little bit more this week later
on but you know this idea that like that
there's no point in trying to deter
crime because you can't by punishing
it this this is an idea this is this is
a it's a it's an idea that
um you know one of these insane Notions
that has filtered its way down from
Academia and then you know it starts an
Academia like so many other crazy ideas
that we can think of especially in
recent history uh starts an Academia and
it filters its way down through all of
our other institutions and then from
there it makes its way into our
communities and destroys
them and this is one of those kinds of
ideas in fact it's one of the most
insane ideas the idea that you cannot
deter crime by punishing
it but it's one that those CNN anchors
obviously
believed which is why they were so
stunned to learn that Florida has
successfully done the thing that's
supposed to be
impossible hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there